how's it going bros my name is Pierre
welcome back to Octodad we're secretly a
octopus you guys been used by now I mean
I got all right let's go and do our [ __ ]
done let's get our living room I don't
think well yeah actually we did the
living room good last time
whatever let's do it again I hate my son
whatever we older to watch this in the
frickin are you doing wait for sports
I'm gonna I carefully have to do this
again it was so difficult
yeah how difficult yes anyway let's do
it
alright you're going down son I don't
care I don't care I don't care I don't
care I don't go get ah alright this time
Matt I don't care go take it take it and
make my back let go let them you like
this position you like it you like this
and I can have my leg up this you can
lick them like this if you know you like
it yeah I can I do that
you like that you like what I do you
know I've made for a session you're like
when I'm alright let's focus on the next
objective hey Reese what race I need to
go step a chair whatever you want
alright okay mace pinky
alright let's go 1 step foot step 2 step
go 1 penis - penis 3 penis how I'm
singing that gah I am NOT gonna let this
stupid hey what am I doing wrong
behind the bar which bar
the [ __ ] kid has a bar holy [ __ ] it's
a brat
let's go out the bus it's one way to win
tower disseminate that that'll hold
let's go to buy it
alright I don't know why now we're now
back to the finish
imma legs desired some March even the
Hama knock the bus go I don't care
[ __ ] this is annoying a table it's got
so much that was free give me the key
[ __ ] give me key suck my balls
Jimmy thick gate ah
why isn't he not giving me oh wait I
have to pick it up alright son son we
discussed this a lot of times and I'm
not really good at pinkish thing up so
please don't give me that face oh wait I
have to keep nevermind wait no wait wait
no down down boy down boy
yes I got a gate of course all right use
the key to open the clock and get the
suit
fine boy but it's the battle
wait that's over first up in the clock
its focus focus
no no turn around and just get this
this is it's impossible
octa dad seriously don't
mouldable oh come on come on nano did I
drop away and then drop it okay let's
there we go yeah give me my suit press
escape to check your journal hit the
story tab hit the story time to get the
lower down through all right we use
Thomas cheetah lock the door we have
done all the [ __ ] we need to do I
believe I don't know if I need this now
there we go got my shoe yeah I know my
[ __ ] no let's get down the BL Stefano
ah no they cut before so we actually
finish the room oh yeah I can't believe
you did that
alright what's going on [ __ ] brat kid
has a TV in his room fly it scream oh no
why would he want to kill an innocent
octopus he's just trying to be as dad
it's not fair
oh did he come
is that it
[Music]
[Applause]
are you drunk again that's usually what
I tell my girlfriend all right I'll just
go to kids through now we already been
there have you been in the kitchen scout
at the kitchen a little local I wonder
why he realized that we're not an
octopus but I don't even want to know
the story of how our kits were made all
right let's try to open this door master
bedroom
all right go girl he's so fine should
find it delicate
I have no idea how these controls work
but I'm doing it
Octodad no you disappoint me a little
more a little yes yes oh come on do you
want from me huh no I don't know let's
try the kids stream there
I thought we finished a kid's room wait
that's the kid strip I'm super confused
right now
no no don't please please please please
please please yes open yes that would
god oh no it's a stupid kid oh whatever
we have to do this sooner or later I'm
the best dad ever
Oh best cover there ever what's that
oh that's not good we can't let her keep
the octo down at all wait what did okay
let's do this [ __ ] all right after that
we're gonna [ __ ] this boy up I don't
know what he is
I'll get you soon octopus
let's [ __ ] fix up that's what I'm
talking about rainbows and unicorns come
at me bro that's what I'm talking about
break - I just love when Heat are so
awesome oh [ __ ] I broke my stuff how do
I climb this it's impossible yes I'll
get you your stupid unicorn do you like
this position
yeah I mean oh the leg oh yeah oh you
like that you like that you like when I
put my leg over you buddy
you like this you like my turn to
college oh man I want to see some
objectives stop the spiders all right
[Music]
whoa they're coming from here so let's
[ __ ] them up let's stick the lamp
No give me the lamp no okay I got the
football kill the spider it should be
dead what are we yeah there we go
i'ma kick you bitter whoa
found a mess rheumatic and honored right
what'd you get not know it yes
no this is really the fill I get it
Adam I get it I'm gay come on take this
one
no yes I got one ah it's a frigging
invitation oh oh damn I'm good I'm good
hi you try to mess with me by trying to
mess with me by oh oh snap I'm an
occupation oh I'm a [ __ ] occupation
girl
now I'm an octopus boy I don't care girl
boy and girl
haters gonna hate
laughs cost you fake haters gonna hate
haters gonna hate hey that's gonna hate
haters gonna hate haters gonna hate
haters they're just gonna hate laughs
because she fake haters gonna hate
well I'm walking in there holy [ __ ]
air walk that's what octopus is here all
right let's get there stupid oh no no we
have to get the clown can't you walk
stairs for some reason I know you're not
to piss on all but come on all right
let's go uh
Octodad
let's take her stupid thing
wow I'm beginning good at the controls
you go girl that means go [ __ ] yourself
[ __ ]
hey let go your stupid fat all right
the thing is we have to get the Blue
Dolphin this is difficult
this is where you fail the last time
alright Octodad see you and me buddy
what are you doing let go that thing
October you're not
oh wait I grabbed it that's why not
throw it away ok let's get the stupid
Blue Dolphin
is it here is this in a ball often what
that no I stupid football all right do
this no I'm just gonna grab [ __ ] usually
what it works that's what I talked to
dad please please be gentle all right
come on out of it shut up and let's get
the Blue Dolphin always actually blowing
growing yellow whatever okay up there
oh yeah whatever
how are its fart sounds any new stuff I
need it down
but up please please [ __ ] please
well is that all right come on bar bar
bur burn really okay boy girl
ass too difficult why you are naive why
you know cooperate after that why you
know [ __ ] cooperate let's go inside
the thing and maybe it works but god is
stupid okay
holy [ __ ] this is difficult
come on yes rainbows and unicorns
wham-o haters gonna hate hate it's gonna
hey hey that's gonna hate oh man yes the
best hitters gonna hey what are you
doing I'm not even doing anything
alright please please can we try it in
today
get her to play some doll for it's all
she has to replace off with all the way
the blue is awesome should work but how
the [ __ ] am I gonna do that let's place
it down first maybe did we do that
quietly escape well haters gonna hate
haters gonna hate haters gonna hate
haters go get her if please wait and
then I'm sorry
yeah missing go see hey just gonna hate
haters gonna hate
yeah come on yes no release yes a lot of
progress today bros anyway I'm gonna
tear hey just gonna hurt oh I like this
song
[Music]
let's knock d'stefano before we end this
come on bro
and that's the final bit wherever I call
you Stefani phone ah I got you now huh
no don't you dare go away from me oh
wait what is that
I got you buddy no now how these games
the [ __ ] miss anyway like a favorite
of you enjoyed I'll see you tomorrow
Bros
[Music]
okay a little boy it's hot I mean ah